en israël pour éviter une
hospitalisation due au plus vite 19 les
statistiques montrent que le vaccin est
efficace à 85% pour les personnes âgées
est à 90% pour les jeunes jusque là rien
de surprenant
pourtant sur la population générale qui
inclut les personnes âgées et les jeunes
le vaccin n'est efficace qu'un 67% ce
nom que se passe-t-il comment est ce
possible
et peut-on imaginer que dans un autre
pays quand bien même le vaccin serait
efficace à 90% pour chaque catégorie
d'âge de la population ils soient
efficaces à dison 10% pour la population
générale
al'inverse est ce possible que le vaccin
soit efficace à 90% pour les jeunes mais
uniquement 10% pour les jeunes hommes et
10% pour les jeunes femmes et si la
réponse est oui à quelles statistiques
faudra-t-il alors se fier qu'est ce
qu'une bonne mesure d'efficacité sur
quels sous population est il judicieux
de calcul et l'efficacité
aujourd'hui on va voir que la réponse à
ces questions sont en fait loin d'être
simple et qu'elle représente un problème
plus général incroyablement vicieux et
dangereux que je vais appeler la
malédiction des généralités en gros la
malédiction des généralités c'est quand
on est obsédé par les généralités et que
ces généralités nous conduisent à des
conclusions trompeuses
pour bien comprendre le paradis a mis en
avant on peut commencer par mieux
définir les chiffres de 85% 92% et 67%
il s'agit de l'efficacité des vaccins
vis-à-vis de l'hospitalisation dont la
définition est un peu piégeuse celle ci
est défini comme étant un mois le ratio
de la probabilité d'être hospitalisé
sachant qu'on n'est pas vacciné par la
probabilité d'être hospitalisé sachant
qu'on est vaccinée ainsi si la
vaccination est efficace probabilité
d'être hospitalisé sachant qu'on est
vacciné devrait être beaucoup plus
petite que la probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on n'est pas
vaccinée ou dit encore autrement leur
rapport devrait être proche de zéro la
mesure quantitative de l'efficacité sera
alors proche de 100% al'inverse si la
vaccination n'a aucun effet alors la
probabilité d'être hospitalisé sachant
qu'on est vacciné devrait alors être à
peu près égale à la probabilité d'être
hospitalisée sachant qu'on n'est pas
vaccinée auquel cas leur rapport serait
égal à à la mesure quantitative de
l'efficacité sera alors proche de zéro
ok maintenant en pratique pour estimer
l'efficacité les probabilités sont
souvent remplacés par les fréquences
dans la population plus précisément en
utilisant la définition des progrès
étaient conditionnels on remplace
d'abord la probabilité conditionnelle
d'être hospitalisée sachant qu'on est
vacciné par le ratio des probabilités
profité d'être hospitalisée et vacciné /
a profité d'être vaccinés puis on peut
remplacer chaque probabilité par leur
fréquence dans la population totale
considéré on obtient alors la
probabilité d'être hospitalisée sachant
qu'on est vaccinée à peu près égal au
nombre d'hospitaliser est vacciné / n le
tout divisé par le nombre de vaccinés /
n où elle est la population totale en
simplifiant on voit que la preuve était
d'être hospitalisée sachant qu'on est
vacciné est à peu près égale au nombre
d'hospitaliser est vacciné divisé par le
nombre de vaccinés de même on estime la
probabilité d'être hospitalisée sachant
qu'on n'est pas vacciné par le nombre de
personnes qui sont hospitalisées et non
vaccinés divisé par le nombre de non
vaccinés et donc dans le cas d'israël si
on calcule ce ratio disons pour les
habitants hospitalisées au cours du mois
dernier on trouve alors 67% et ça c'est
bien sûr très étrange puisque c'est
beaucoup moins que ce qui était annoncé
il ya huit mois et pour tout vous dire
quand j'ai vu ce chiffre je ne me suis
pas posé plus de questions que cela je
me suis dit ah merde les vaccins sont
moins efficaces contre le variant tel
tas le lait du passé était tombé à pieds
joints dans le paradoxe de simpson dont
on va parler dans la suite et cet idiot
ne s'en était même pas rendu compte bon
à sa décharge c'est parce que le lait du
passé a rapidement survoler un fred qui
réagissait à la statistique six
hospitalisés sur dix sont vaccinés qui
est une statistique trompeuse au pineau
paris deux reprises aux précédents non
pas à cause du paradoxe de simpson mais
parce qu'elle ne tient pas compte et des
préjugés et en particulier du taux de
base des vaccinés bref tout ça pour dire
que quand on met deux mes informations
boudabbous le lait du passé peut dans
des bunkers une dans sa tête et croire
qu'il a fait son % du travail ce qui le
rend très vulnérables à la seconde
ok mais le truc vraiment bizarre quatre
suites dont j'ai envie de parler
aujourd'hui dans le cas des statistiques
d'israël c'est que alors que
l'efficacité générale du vaccin
vis-à-vis de l'hospitalisation est de
67% son efficacité pour les moins de 50
ans et de 92% et son efficacité pour les
plus de 50 ans est de 85% comment est ce
possible que les statistiques par
tranche d'âge soit aussi grande alors
que la statistique général est aussi
faible si vous êtes troublé par cette
observation je vous renvoie à
l'excellente vidéo de david sur le sujet
ou à celle que j'ai fait avec un exemple
de football de façon cruciale le
paradoxe simpson montre à quel point les
généralités sont trompeuses et pas juste
parce qu'elles sont incorrectes de façon
extrêmement contre intuitive même quand
elles sont parfaitement factuelle mais
même quand elle s'appuie sur des
chiffres tout à fait justes et sur des
calculs sans aucune erreur les
généralités peuvent aisément nous
induire en erreur elles peuvent nous
faire croire que radio est meilleur que
quand et où de manière plus critique au
corps que l'efficacité des vaccins
contre le variant delta vis-à-vis de
l'hospitalisation pour vous n'est que de
60 7%
quel est ce que j'appelle la malédiction
des généralités c'est le fais tu te
croire que lorsqu'elles sont factuels
les statistiques générales nous
fournissent nécessairement des
informations fiables et non trompeuse
mais ce n'est pas le cas dès lors que
celles-ci sont sujettes à des facteurs
de confusion comme l'âge des patients
c'est à dire des variables qui
influencent à la fois les populations
comparer et leur sort il faut absolument
se méfier de ces statistiques générales
le paradoxe de simpson est certainement
l'un des théorèmes mathématiques les
plus terrifiants à comprendre surtout
dans le contexte de la crise épistémique
actuelle si vous vous contentez de
généralités factuels pour conclure vous
êtes garantie de commettre un nombre
incalculable d'erreurs surtout sur des
sujets où le parti pris nous conduit à
énormément de raisonnement motivé
malheureusement à l'heure actuelle ni le
grand public ni les journalistes ni même
les scientifiques ne me semble avoir
pris la mesure de la malédiction de la
généralité ainsi en sciences la quasi
totalité des articles sont encore obsédé
par la quête de différence générale par
exemple sur l'efficacité d'un traitement
où les différences entre des
sous-populations typiquement hommes
femmes avec bien trop peu de
considération pour les risques de mes
informations du à la malédiction des
généralités et clairement la traduction
fréquentes ista coup de [ __ ] yeux
n'aide vraiment pas
dès lors il n'est pas étonnant de
constater une prolifération de mes
informations dangereuses guidés par des
généralités parfaitement factuelle
alors je suis sûr que vous voulez mieux
comprendre le cas des vaccins comment
est ce possible que en général leur
efficacité puisse être de 60 7% alors
qu'elle est de plus de 85% pour les
jeunes et pour les moins jeunes pour
vraiment comprendre l'intuition derrière
le paradoxe simpson imaginons le cas
extrême où toutes les personnes âgées
sont vaccinés et toutes les personnes
jeunes ne sont pas vaccinés à ce moment
là les vaccinés sont exactement les
personnes âgées et les non vaccinés sont
exactement les jeunes mais alors quand
on compare l'hospitalisation des
vaccinés à celle des non vaccinés on
compare surtout l'hospitalisation des
vieux vacciner à celle des jeunes non
vaccinés or comme les vieux sont
beaucoup plus à risque et de base même
une fois vacciner il de morts
potentiellement encore autant à risque
que les jeunes n'ont vacciné si tel est
le cas la statistique d'efficacité
général conclura que les vaccins ne sont
pas efficaces bien sûr dans le cas
d'israël on n'est pas tout à fait là
puisqu'il ya tout de même 73% de
vaccination parmi les moins de 50 ans ce
n'est pas si loin des 90 % pour les plus
de 50 ans néanmoins cette différence
suffit à faire en sorte que les vaccinés
soit aussi plus probablement vieux et
donc quand même pas mal à risque à cause
de l'orage par opposition à des non
vaccinés qui sont plus probablement plus
jeune est donc partiellement protégés
par l'orage ceci dit et de façon très
préoccupante notre raisonnement montre
que dans un autre pays avec des
circonstances différentes pourvu que le
vieux vacciner demeure davantage à
risque que les jeunes n'ont vacciné il
est tout à fait concevable que la
statistique général suggère désormais la
dangerosité des vaccins autrement dit
dans un tel pays surtout si les jeunes
ne se vaccinent pas on peut très bien
avoir une efficacité générale des
vaccins qui deviennent négatives les
statistiques générales suggérerait alors
à tort que les vaccins sont néfastes et
qu'on y perd à se vacciner et ça en fait
petit prix banking ça risque en fait
d'arriver dans les pays déjà beaucoup
affecté si ces personnes déjà infectées
ne sont pas encouragés à se faire
vacciner j'insiste un peu plus encore
sur cette possibilité terrifiante en
effet on pourrait en arriver à comparer
des déjà infecté non vaccinés ad non
infectés vacciner or les infectés n'ont
vacciné semble plus tg que les non
infectés vacciner autre explication
importante le pass sanitaires celui-ci
encourage et non infectés à se vacciner
beaucoup plus d'une encourage les
infectés à se vacciner ainsi la
comparaison entre vacciner et non
vaccinés risque d'être dans les mois à
venir de plus en plus une comparaison
entre des non infectés vacciner et
désinfecter non vaccinés mais ce n'est
pas tout qui plus est grâce au pass
sanitaire n'est vacciné devrait beaucoup
plus aller au restaurant ou au cinéma ce
qui augmente leur exposition au co vide
si cette exposition est dix fois
supérieur ce seul phénomène de
surexposition des vaccinés suffira en
fait à faire en sorte que la probabilité
qu'un vacciner doivent aller à l'hôpital
soit aussi grande que la probabilité
qu'un nom vexim et iai bref ou combinant
toutes ces raisons pour lesquelles les
vaccinés forme a priori une population
plus vulnérable et exposée
il semble en fait probable que dans les
mois à venir au moins quelque part en
france la population des vaccinés soit
plus à risque de se retrouver à
l'hôpital que la population des non
vaccinés quand bien même pour chaque
individu toute exposition au virus
égales par ailleurs le vaccin demeure
efficace à 90%
tel est l'ampleur de la malédiction de
la généralité mais parce que le jour où
ça ça arrive vous pouvez être sûr que
les rayons de la fnac seront remplis de
propos très dangereusement trompeur mais
parfaitement justifiée par des
généralités entièrement factuel mais
soumis à cette horrible paradoxe des
simpson
alors vous qui connaissez
le paradoxe de simpson vous vous dites
peut-être que vous pourrez maintenant
aller sur twitter et prendre de haut
tous ceux qui tombent dans le piège de
ce paradoxe mais avant de faire cela
posez vous la question dans le cadre des
statistiques d'israël on attend vraiment
fini avec ce paradoxe est ce que en
partageant les statistiques par tranche
d'âge on a vraiment résolu la
malédiction généralité après tout les
statistiques pour les moins de 50 ans en
israël même si c'est moins général que
de parler de la population générale en
israël ça reste une statistique général
non mais du coup le chiffre de 92 % pour
les moins de 50 ans ne pourrait-il pas
lui même être sujets au paradoxe de
simpson est ce possible par exemple que
si on re découvre cette population des
moins de 50 ans par genre par origine
ethnique ou par localisation
géographique ou par niveau socio
économique ou par antécédents médicaux
notamment vis-à-vis des infections
antérieure aux copies de 10,9 est-ce
possible qu'en regardant davantage de
facteurs de confusion où on retrouve
alors d efficacité du vaccin toutes
égales à dison 10% à quel moment peut-on
conclure qu'une statistique général
n'est plus soumise à la malédiction des
généralités alors je vous ne pas savoir
exactement ce que répondrait un
statisticien fréquentes east à ces
questions les à en croire ce que j'ai
cités notamment dans l'épisode 13
certains fréquentent east proposerait
peut-être de se fier à la connaissance
d'un extérieur c'est en tout cas ce que
suggère des lillois prudent son ex en
vidéo sur le paradoxe de simpson si tel
est le cas j'ai envie de dire qu'il
s'agit là avant tout d'une résolution
partiellement bayésienne de la
malédiction des généralités car elle
fait finalement appel aux préjugés de
l'expert c'est à dire d'un jugement
préalable qui s'appuient sur des
informations complètement absente des
statistiques qui lui sont présentés quoi
qu'il en soit si on adopte pleinement la
casquette by then il est clair que ces
préjugés sont absolument critique pour
éviter la malédiction des généralités en
particulier imaginons que la seule chose
que vous sachiez c'est que l'efficacité
générale des vaccins en israël est égal
à 67% que feriez vous de cette donnée
carreman à cause du paradoxe simpson
vous ne pourrez pas l'utiliser pour
conclure que l'efficacité pour un
individu donné sera de 67 % mais est ce
pour autant qu'il faut ignorer cette
donnée dès lors qu'elle est soumise
quel de paradoxes de simpson la
généralité doit-elle être complètement
ignorés et si oui peut-on alors
considéré que toute statistique est une
généralité et ignorer ainsi tout des
statistiques pour le parisien en tout
cas la réponse est non toute statistique
est une donnée et toutes données doit
être exploitée pour mettre à jour de
crédence cependant cette mise à jour
doit obéir rigoureusement aux lois des
probabilités
ce qui dans le cas des données
observationnelles peut être piégeux en
fait pour bien effectuer cela pour le
billysien il faut absolument interpréter
cette donnée dans le cadre de
différentes théories qui nous semblent
crédibles et ci étant donné typiquement
des estimations des taux de vaccination
chez les jeunes et les moins jeunes et
sachant la vulnérabilité plus grande des
moins jeunes nous semble alors probable
d'obtenir une efficacité générale de 60%
alors le chiffre de 67 % devra alors
vous faire légèrement augmenté nos
crédence en l'efficacité du vaccin en
s'appuyant sur le bannissement et en
particulier sur les préjugés on peut
également justifier l'existence de
certaines statistiques moins sujette à
la malédiction des généralités et donc
probablement plus désirable à
communiquer en pratique typiquement si
nous paraît très crédible que l'âge est
un facteur de confusion qui s'il est
pris en compte change complètement les
mesures d'efficacité il paraîtra alors
désirable de calculer les statistiques
par tranche d'âge al'inverse en pratique
on peut considérer qu'une statistique
général est suffisamment non trompeuse
si paraît peu crédible à ceux qui s'y
connaissent le mieux qu'elle puisse être
subdivisée en statistiques plus
spécifiques radicalement distincte mais
s'il ya avant tout une chose à retenir
de l'analyse parisienne du paradoxe de
simpson peut être plus encore que le
rôle central des préjugés pour le
décortiquer c'est le fait que en
pratique les probabilités qui compte
vraiment ce ne sont pas les statistiques
générales dans ma balance
risque/bénéfice pour décider de me
vacciner ne me faut en fait pas regardé
à des statistiques comme la probabilité
d'être hospitalisée sachant qu'on est
vaccinée ou qu'on n'est pas vaccinée non
dans mon cas personnel les probabilités
qui compte ce sont les probabilités
d'être hospitalisé sachant qu'on est
vacciné et qu'on est l'individu les par
opposition à la priorité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on n'est pas
vacciné et qu'on est l'un des les ou
dans le fait de conditionner parler on
tient en compte de mon âge mon genre
l'origine ethnique ma localisation
géographique au niveau socio-économique
et en fait même avant tout mes
antécédents médicaux est ce assez
critique à comprendre car en probabilité
on sait très bien que la probabilité
conditionnelle probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on est vacciné et
qu'on est les est en général très
différente de la probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on est vacciné
les informations additionnelles peuvent
complètement bouleversé nos estimations
de la probabilité d'un événement donné
malheureusement de nos jours dans les
médias sur les réseaux sociaux et dans
la recherche scientifique les
généralités reste ce qui prédomine et on
oublie trop souvent de conditionner
adéquatement nos estimations
probabiliste à titre d'exemple une
publication récente dans serious ouvre
par la conclusion que la protection par
une infection antérieur est plus grande
que celle par la vaccination autrement
dit le résultat phare de cette
publication en tout cas c'est lé cas
mais largement en avant c'est une
comparaison entre la probabilité d'être
hospitalisée sachant qu'on a été
infectée précédemment et la probabilité
d'être hospitalisé sachant qu'on a été
précédemment vacciner cependant à bien y
réfléchir ces quantités ont très peu
d'intérêt pratique notamment pour la
vaccination à titre individuel ce qui
importe c'est davantage la probabilité
d'être hospitalisée sachant qu'on a été
précédemment infectés et qu on est
vaccinés par opposition à la probabilité
d'être hospitalisé sachant qu'on a été
précédemment infectés et qu'on n'ait
toujours pas vaccinées en tout cas dans
le cas des individus infectés et pour
les personnes qui ne sont pas infectés
ce qui importe c'est de comparer la
probabilité d'être hospitalisé sachant
qu'on n'a pas été précédemment affectés
par le kobe 19 et qu on est vacciné pas
opposition à la probabilité d'être
hospitalisé sachant qu'on n'a pas été
précédemment infectés et qu'on n'est pas
vaccinée ce n'est malheureusement que
dans un second temps que ces
statistiques plus importantes sont cités
dont la publication est effroyable elle
suggère fortement qu'on y gagne à être
vaccinés qu'on ait été infectés
préalablement ou non
malheureusement même les scientifiques
n'ont pas développé d'immunité robuste
face à la terrible malédiction dégénère
lité mais face à l'importance de
conditionner adéquatement les
probabilités qu'on évalue et qu'on
communique il est grand temps que
ensemble on cherche tous à faire mieux